[Music]  true story new research says that one  minute of vigorous intense exercise is  just as effective as 45 minutes of  moderate exercise they're equally the  same I bring us up for a reason I did  been busy very busy today not working on  the material clearly but I I did not get  a chance to work out this morning and  according to this story I can take care  of that entire workout which is usually  45 minutes long in my case in just one  minute  are you guys cool with me just doing  right now in a minute my favorite my  favorite strenuous exercise is beating  six pinatas you could be doing  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  there was only five pinatas where is my  sixth pinata I'm not gonna beat up an  image of myself that's I got it  [Applause]  handy okay the pinata is gone all right  it's gone it's dead  you